alors est ce que la délinquance des
mineurs explose en france oui et non
c'est sûr on a des réseaux aujourd'hui
de criminels et de délinquance en trafic
de produits stupéfiants très
particulièrement où les mineurs sans
employer car ils ne risquent pas grand
chose pénalement
donc c'est un peu leur assurance c'est à
dire ils utilisent des mineurs pour
siffler quand la police arrive
il utilise des mineurs pour vendre des
produits stupéfiants est derrière les
poursuites sont assez minimes elle
commence régulièrement avec un rappel à
la loi
est-ce que c'est incompréhensible l'eau
ça fait le sujet d'un autre départ mais
en tout cas des sanctions elles sont
très faibles par rapport aux faits
incriminés
alors j'ai beaucoup aimé la réponse est
non parce que bien évidemment il ya du
nom il ya du nom est vrai que l'unc ans
de manière générale n'a pas du tout
explosé il suffit de regarder les
statistiques du ministère de la justice
il faut aussi savoir qu' il ya beaucoup
plus large et notamment des nouveaux par
actions qui ont été créés ou depuis une
dizaine d'années ces paravents et
également la fameuse tolérance zéro
c'est à dire qu'on les mineurs sont
beaucoup plus poursuivi que les majeurs
puisqu'il poursuite de faits punissables
jusqu'à 93%
il faut savoir que nous sommes le pays
d'europe qui est incarcéré le plus nos
enfants et il faut savoir que nous
sommes le pays d'europe qui aussi
infligent les plaines les plus lourdes à
nos enfants
je dirais qu'il ya un phénomène
automatiquement sociologique qui fait
qu' on a plus de chances de devenir des
délinquants dans certains endroits
maintenant en tant que policier on est
contre la culture de l'excusé un moment
donné il faut aussi responsabiliser les
gens responsabiliser les parents sur les
faits commis par les enfants c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on a des quartiers
en france où on laisse les enfants ont
parlé des guetteurs tout à l'heure par
exemple on laisse clairement les enfants
toute la journée dehors jusqu'à des 22
23 heures une heure des fois de 14 de 15
ans il ya un moment donné il faut
responsabiliser les parents parce qu'il
ya des parents qui ont complètement
lâché prise par volonté peut-être
peut-être aussi par lassitude
parce qu'ils sont fatigués de répéter
toujours les mêmes choses parce que
certains ont peur de leurs enfants
c'est de plus en plus courant quand même
que des adolescents frappent leurs
parents on retrouve souvent chez les
mères isolées dans ce cas là où les
mères n'arrive pas à faire face ont de
leurs enfants
et puis se retrouve avec un enfant
violent si elle aura interdit de sortir
le soir c'est leur interdit de
fréquenter telle ou telle personne
donc il ya un vrai problème je dirais
social mais un moment donné si des
parents sont responsabilisés en fin de
semaine se retrouvent eux aussi face à
la justice pour les agissements de leurs
enfants
je suis certain qu'on aurait une
répercussion sur le comment dire sur le
maintien en tout cas sur le sur la
droiture de leurs enfants
d'abord évidemment la responsabilité
pénale n'est pas possible il ya il faut
une imputabilité in et j'avais également
culpabilité et que y'a pas à dire c'est
pas parce que votre gamin est allé
donner un coup de pouce dans la rue du
coup vous avez vous lui avez dit oui si
vous lui assigner le gamin dit mon père
ma mère m'a dit d'aller dans la rue et
de donner un coup de poing ou m'a remis
un couteau dans la main pour aller
poignarder quelqu'un là où bien
évidemment quelques possibilités pétales
et si un gamin ou une gamine a commis
des actes de délinquance ailleurs
responsable pénal parce qu'il n'ya pas
les parents m'ont parfait le stade
rémy qui ont permis à l'enfant de
commettre en traction ont la
responsabilité pénale
j'ai découvert avec effarement 1 qu' il
y à 23 % des familles qui sont défaits
en france qui sont les familles
monoparentales c'est à dire une personne
seule est souvent vous en avez parlé
d'ailleurs vous avez dit la mère et que
ce sont des familles qui peuvent se
retrouver en grande difficulté puisque
ce sont aussi les familles les plus
pauvres les plus pauvres qui se retrouve
une situation
je suis d'accord il y en a très
difficile mais moi ce que je veux ce que
je les ai vécues mais c'est ceux ci
durera c'est que tu tout le monde signer
si tout le monde s'y met à sa place sans
angélisme jamais en excuses y compris
nos avocats
jamais on est là pour dire au ghana
t'inquiète pas jamais jamais jab b et
bien je peux vous dire qu'on arrive à en
sortir même soit disant plus avec mon
récupérables parce que ces gamins
or il se lève ils ont rien comme projet